[Music]
it's a pretty sweet gig that we've got
here to act as a tour guide through the
macrocosmos and we've been fortunate to
be joined by you fellow travelers
bringing all of your insightful thoughts
and very funny clips and also good
questions in the comments section so for
today we wanted to turn it around and
let some of the most frequent questions
we've received guide this episode so we
can talk more about how things work by
the scenes here and how it impacts this
journey many of you have asked how we
find and care for our microscopic
friends
well James our collector of microbes and
master of microscopes takes samples
literally from everywhere he can but his
favorite spot is a park just next to his
house collecting these samples requires
some high-tech equipment like a selfie
stick which James bought and converted
into a portable sampling stick that lets
him reach tough spots it's lightweight
it's collapsible what else do you need
once we have collected our specimens we
can't ignore them we have to take care
of them keep them alive and thriving for
James that means a few things protecting
them from environmental factors like
direct sunlight or sudden changes in
temperature while also providing them
with a nutritious setting that allows
them to grow this of course looks
different for different microbes for
algae James adds a couple drops of
liquid plant fertilizer into the water
and gives them some natural sunlight but
heterotrophs like ciliates and
flageolets they need food and James has
a number of different homemade solutions
that provide that sustenance from nearly
the beginning of microbe hunting a
favorite food has been a hay infusion
and that is something that James uses as
well it's basically just boiled hay
other times he might sprinkle some
cooked rice grains into the sample or
add drops of milk it's a whole menu
designed to suit different organisms but
no matter what they demand the gold is
the same to make sure we're taking care
of our little pond buddies now to the
most frequent question of all our
equipment when it comes time to get a
closer to look at our cultures we've
used two different microscopes to film
the footage you've seen on this channel
the first one is a microscope that James
cobbled together from various parts for
just under two hundred dollars creating
hundreds of hours of recorded footage
that we still use so this one is a micro
cosmos original you can't buy it there
is only one and there is no brand name
after we launched the channel James got
a sponsorship from a microscope company
may be the most niche and we think one
of the coolest sponsorships you can get
and since then he's used a modak be a
310 microscope and a fuji film xt3
camera
with this microscope we've been able to
expand on the kind of footage we can
show thanks to the different types of
light we can use like these paramecia
that we observed under polarized light
we're very excited about all the
different forms of light you can use
with this microscope and what they
reveal about the micro cosmos and you
will see more of that in future episodes
another common question how do we
prepare and observe our samples how do
we actually get a look at these
organisms well the procedure is fairly
similar each time we first take a drop
from our samples and place that on a
glass slide and then we cover that drop
with another super thin piece of glass
called a cover slip that creates an
extremely thin film of water between
those two pieces of glass and that is
what we observe when we make our videos
some of you have asked why we can see
microbes moving left right up and down
but they never seem to move towards or
away from us of course microbes live in
a three-dimensional universe but our
footage does not always reflect that
because of how microscopes work high
magnification objectives that we use
have a low depth of field meaning the
area that is in focus is a very thin
slice so we forced the micro cosmos into
a two dimensional space this very thin
area between the two pieces of glass now
sometimes we actually make that area
thicker for larger organisms by putting
some stuff under the coverslip maybe
it's some decaying plant matter or some
tiny grains of sand in those cases
however it becomes easier for those
organisms to wander out of focus
our microscope also shapes the way we
observe the color of these organisms are
often what seems to be the lack thereof
we've been asked why so many of them are
transparent and well transparency comes
down to two things first how much light
there is and second how much stuff there
is blocking that light in the case of
microscopic observation there is a lot
of light and the bodies are tiny some of
these organisms just lack the pigments
that would make them colorful but for
others the light source and the
microscope is just too strong
overpowering their pigments so they
appear to our eyes transparent you would
be transparent too if you are only a few
microns thick some of you also want to
know whether we use stains to create our
footage stains are a common laboratory
and medical technique that uses dyes to
bind at the different parts of cells and
thus help visualize their components and
processes while they are often beautiful
and very informative stains can also be
harmful to cells potentially even
killing them so we have chosen to keep
the microorganisms unstained there have
also been questions about what our
magnification notes mean those a little
100 X's and 200 X's you see up in the
corner those numbers refer specifically
to the magnification created by the
microscope not how much larger the image
is as it appears on your screen
relative to its actual size now that is
a subtle difference but subtle
differences can be very important after
all some of you are watching this on
your phones others are watching on a
computer screen others might be watching
on a big 70 inch flat screen on your
wall and if you are that's awesome thank
you we however do not know what size
device you're watching this on but
you're seeing the same
100 X in the corner because that
describes the optics of the microscope
not the size of the screen you're using
to watch youtube videos to fix this
we've gotten a lot of comments asking us
to use a scale bar instead of the
magnification and we've been thinking
about non intrusive ways of implementing
that and finally we've had questions
about how real-time our footage is we
always make sure to note whether the
footage we're showing has been sped up
sometimes the microbes we show you are
super chill and relaxed and sometimes
they are very much not chill moving
faster than many of us might expect
we're asked sometimes whether any
particular piece of footage has been
sped up and rest assured that unless
we've noted it that very active microbe
is just very active
I mean calm down friend you could take a
breather
and so can all of us every once in a
while thank you so much for all your
questions and all your comments over
these months we hope that by answering
them you find new things to ponder and
ask us about the micro cosmos the
question that doesn't pose new questions
is no question at all and if say you are
wondering whether this channel reminds
us of the cell stage in the game Spore
the answer is of course yes yes it very
much does thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us we also just
recently launched our very first piece
of micro cosmos merch I'm wearing it
right now though you cannot see that
because there's no cameras on me but I
promise I am its ass tender karolius
pin and the image of the stint ER on the
pin is roughly 40 X the size of what a
real world
Julius is so when people see it you can
tell them that and you can own this
little piece of the macrocosmos
there's a link in the description thank
you so much to all of our patrons on
patreon who make it possible for us to
do this weird thing that we love doing
and if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James you can
check out Jam and germs on Instagram and
of course if you want to subscribe to
journey to the micro cosmos I bet you
can figure out how to do that